for me all I wanted to do was be myself
but I wanted to be myself in this
community of people it's your rite of
passage with them for them to believe
that you're talented for them to believe
that you know what good food tastes like
that is celebrity chef Christina Tosi
showing off her skills on the popular
series chefs table
the show takes viewers around the world
to see the mouth-watering and innovative
dishes served up by culinary stars
now it's creator David geld shifting his
focus to the streets of Asia in his new
series Street food it brings people to
places like Singapore where the
traditional putu peering dish is rooted
in cultural history they place the rice
floor into the little metal tins and
then they put the metal tins into the
steamer this is rhythm to it it's served
with grated coconut and squares of
pandan leaf so it has that subtle sweet
vanilla fragrance
I've got so much history and when you
mention it to anyone in Singapore
everyone knows about tiendas oh yeah I
used to eat it as a kid it looks so
peaceful david helvey is the co-creator
of street food on netflix welcome thank
you so much for having me so that was a
beautiful clip but why street food why
why did you go that dirge well while we
were making chef's table we're spending
time in these incredible cities in
Southeast Asia and we would go with the
chefs and with the kind of assistance in
the kitchen they would take us to their
favorite spots to eat and often they
would be these little carts on the
street and these chefs have just as much
passion as the chefs in any very fancy
restaurant well it's so beautifully done
you know it's like cinematic
storytelling if you will that's how I
already described but the thing is the
chef's that you choose all have such
interesting backstory like the lady that
we saw Jay Jay v j5 or the guy who says
River eels will get or an aphrodisiac
they're freaked me out watching it but
they all have very interesting stories
so are you looking for those types of
people do sure so much like chef's table
Street food is really character and
story focus and so when you're watching
our show you know you'll get a sense of
what they're cooking and how they do it
but it's really about why they cook and
getting to the really emotional kind of
origin stories of some of the best and
most interesting chefs that you'll find
in the streets of Southeast Asia
and why is it why do they call yeah well
we always consider our chefs are kind of
like superheroes in a way you know and
they all have an origin story there's
something in their childhood their
adolescence that makes them realize they
have this incredible power to make
delicious food and their food also tells
a story and the food often tells the
story of their lives and that's what
you'll see on our show how do you see
that this there's a cultural shift in
food here in the United States well I
think that people are learning to
appreciate food and to think about what
they're eating more and so I think
you're seeing better restaurants you're
seeing more kind of foreign food and
foreign influences coming into the
United States in terms of you know food
trucks and food halls and you're also
seeing a lot more kind of specialization
and in Street food some of our shops
have been working on the exact same dish
for 30 40 50 years and they're so
they're just part of their community
it's been said about you that you've
turned food porn into an art form
so
what did you see david that you thought
there is something here that people will
want to see what you see well you know
we like to call it food romance okay so
it sounds better than fool yeah because
there's context in a story and I think
that what makes the food more beautiful
and more delicious is this idea that you
know these are real people and their
lives their passion all that context
makes the food look and taste you tell
such great food stories do you cook
yourself oh I do yes and my mom is an
excellent cook as well what's your mom's
name
Donna geld she has a book out called
salad ish right now salad ish Thank You
Danielle Donna gillip son thank you very
much nicely done and go Netflix it's
called streaming food it's streaming
right now isn't matter though it's
called street food sorry David goes no
it's called sweet food streaming right
now on Netflix we'll be right back
you